[Applaudissements]
michael jerome browne vice président
de huawei c'est sur les bancs de la fac
est
changée pas fait un truc je sais pas
veuillez patienter votre correspondant
vous a mis en attente
non c'est bon ça va merci de rappeler
ultérieurement
arrête de faire des trucs comme ça
arrête en plus ça me stresse
22 rue campion à paris 22 rue de paris
vous donner vie non non j'ai pas rues de
paris je vais rue confions
22e campion à paris maintenant un troll
j'ai pas mis d'adressent
j'atteinds heures une option à paris
parce que là ça commence à m'énerver
madame
rue
campion du il dit me
sélectionner jantes rentrée gens là
n'est pas cette ville moubarak à notre
ouïe ouïe
oui voilà oui oui
alors pourquoi j'ai trois paquets de
smarties un vide un autre vide étant
d'accord je vais bouger le plein et tu
vas me dire où il se trouve
et la vie prend le souverain
un vide un bien
2e série 2e
attend attend
quel est ce que
zahia aurait rappelé
hier
j'aime trop faire les voix de disney
channel mais je vous jure j'ai trop peur
de rester bloqués ne sais pas je suis
avec mon crash en haute savoie ouais ça
fait longtemps vous regardez les
sorciers de waverly place sur disney
channel pardon c'est archi démence a
sûrement j'ai envie d'avoir une image un
peu stricte en plus un peu de ghettos et
tout à taper il ya personne encore